confusion mélange des genres inversion
des rôles
c'est le mariage burlesque pour ce lundi
gras dans les rues de fort-de-france et
cérémonies ont une fois de plus
interpellé plus d'un et dit la maîtresse
mécontentes et sa robe début 19e
il a tout fait lui-même environ 300
euros c'est long mais bon comme je suis
passionné je ne vois pas le temps passer
alors ce que l'on appelait la prime au
lean en fait que l'on appelle encore là
pris nos lignes voilà mais j'ai fait
pour qu'il puisse y avoir la même forme
qu'il y a on va dire 150 ans comme en
1860 il dans cet autre rue mariage petit
budget très calculée mais pas
véritablement discret ex copine qui m'a
fait cadeau
c2c du rhum et j'ai donné à mon potter
vous pensez qu'elle a été utilisée pour
vrai mariage et non non je ne pense pas
je ne bosse pas nous le mariage à trois
de petits trois tendances une centaine
d'euros paraît pause et un shoot de 44
10 euros debout que 5 euros la robe 25
euros le jupon c'est des vrais jumeaux
j'ai fait des mariages qui se suivent
mais qui ne se ressemblent pas le
burlesque traverse ainsi les décennies
apparu pour se moquer de la haute
société de l'establishment
cette année la ville de fort de france a
tenté le recensement des couples qui se
sont dit oui pour se le dit gras 2019
[Applaudissements]